the police took four five shots in them
for no reason oh my god please don't
tell me he's dead please don't tell me
my boyfriend just went like that
football you will see with your own eyes
how he was handed unjustly I am Nicholas
be with reasontv we are in Las Vegas at
Freedom Fest and we are talking to Neill
Franklin he's the executive director of
Law Enforcement Against Prohibition leap
he's a former Maryland state trooper and
officer of training for the city of
Baltimore Neil thanks for talking to us
always great to talk to you Nick we are
in a situation where police and
community relations seem to be at an
all-time low when you look at groups
like Gallup and other polling
organizations show a decline in the
level of trust and confidence that
people have in law enforcement when you
look at what happened in Louisiana and
Minnesota recently where police shot and
killed either unarmed or passive people
are people right to be skeptical of the
way that police interact with them you
know in talking about these issues we
tend to go back maybe a year or two but
that's not what it's really about it's
about decades of problem policing and
communities of color and poor
communities it's not yes race is a big
part in the communities of races it's a
big part to it but it's also a class
issue as well historically in this
country the police have never really
been the Friends of the black community
I mean come on I mean you know we're
only a couple hundred years of that out
of slavery you know in a slave patrols
mainly in the south of rounding up you
know runaway slaves and so on and much
of our policing was born out of that
especially in the South post-slavery we
had Jim Crow laws where laws which still
enabled us to imprison black citizens
you know for not having a home not
having a job vacancy coming forward
today look at the war on drugs which you
can't have you can only have a war on
people overwhelmingly and it might just
be the recent examples but typically
you're pulled over in a car because you
have
something wrong then you get a ticket
then that ticket gets a fine attached to
it when you don't pay it because you
don't have money or you don't go to
court have we shifted out of you know I
are added to the war on drugs then as a
means of social control a kind of over
policing police about religion Lisa have
always been tax collectors and
unfortunately certain communities bear
that burden more than others you know
250 doll fine doesn't mean much to
people who have money paid a fine and I
go on I get another one tomorrow so no
big deal but when you enforce these
policies and poor communities a hundred
dollar fine can devastate a family not
just the person then what happens when
you don't pay it and when you don't pay
it it affects your driver's license
typically they suspended you gotta drive
to go back and forth to work paid 100
dollar fine that you got but you just
weren't able to pay it in time or
whatever now you get stopped again do
police I mean do they systematically are
they trained or do they do it out of
habit do they pull over bad car traffic
stops with a broken taillight come on a
tag light out you know you drifted out
of your lane we use that as a tool to
search we use that as a tool to look for
guns to look for drugs see if you want
it for crime basically at the end of the
day is what it boils down to is
harassment you know in Dallas during a
black lives matters protest against
police brutality 5 Dallas policemen were
killed as a former police officer when
you hear something like that like how
does that make you feel the Dallas
situation one of the first things in
addition to feeling the pain of the
families of those five police officers
in addition to filling that the other
thing that came to mind was this service
that we have done to our Police brothers
and sisters in this country when I say
we I'm talking about our politicians and
I'm talking about the policies that we
have passed and continue to pass such as
drug prohibition where we're trying to
solve a public health crisis with
criminal justice solutions and our cops
are the tip of the spear and we have
this conflict and community as we stop
them whether they're driving walking to
search them pull their pockets inside
out
stop-and-frisk in New York when we
noticed the disaster that was a police
are put in harm's way not just with each
encounter but in black brown and poor
communities the police are despised for
doing this work and the police leaders
require this of these minimum its
numbers again so it's of the status of
our politician so I mean if you know and
I obviously speaking broadly here but
you know if cops have their choice they
wouldn't be going after its kind of
their choice we'd be going after
murderers rapists robbers helping
families with domestic violence issues
we'd be going after people who are
targeting and hurting people not trying
to be someone's guardian we don't want
to be you know don't get me wrong as a
member of a community yes we become
mentors we become teachers for young
people we even become somewhat of a
social worker from time to time but it
shouldn't be your duty you know we
shouldn't be doing the things that
others should wear all this you have
that response are you are you optimistic
about the future I mean we are seeing
discussions and movement on criminal
justice reform sentencing reform places
in the country have repealed marijuana
prohibition it looks like California
probably will is the war on drugs ending
are you are you optimistic that we're
entering a phase that we're cops will be
asked to do less dumb things what we're
seeing now what marijuana reform the
attention it's being brought to heroin
still there's some problem areas there
but we're starting to see people look at
this as a health issue for what it is
with some of the harder drugs marijuana
to realizing that hey let's end it let's
move I didn't expect it along with other
members of League we didn't expect this
to happen in our lifetime so we're very
happy about that and we see great
movement there it relates to policing in
this country we need a completely new
model of policing it's like what we have
now is not like trying to fix a broken
car this car was a used car in the first
place as I was saying before going
back to post slavery was used car in a
first place it never did work we were
constantly trying to repair it and
tinker with it you know it comes a time
in your life where you say you know I
got to get rid of this I need a new car
with a warranty and something that's
going to do what needs to be done to get
me from point A to point B what what are
the preconditions to have an honest
conversation about that where you know
both blacks and whites and and other you
know ethnic ethnic groups poor and rich
can start to rebuild trust and
confidence in the both in the
institution of poor communities you know
that these are people who can actually
take care of themselves and live
meaningful lives and also most
importantly police and law enforcement
what are the preconditions to have that
kind of reboot that you're talking about
the first thing we need is a
reconciliation and I say that it should
come from the police first it needs to
come from many different places but it
needs to come from our politicians in
the police first why because we have the
power and it's more than a conversation
we really need to communicate to the
point where we really understand the
perspectives we understand the
perspectives of people and black brown
and poor communities and what they're
dealing with they understand what we're
faced with in policing and the policies
and things that we are tasked with
enforcing and then we all need to work
together not just participate but to
commit can I ask as a final question
what is what's your opinion of black
lives matter do you think they are a
force for starting this conversation or
are they you know a lot of conservatives
certainly but even a lot of people on
the Left seem to really dislike black
lives matter what do you want they're
focusing on the lives and when I say
lives of blacks at the hands of
government they're not just talking
about deaths they're talking about being
able to thrive as a people within their
communities so they're talking about the
lack of proper health care they're
talking about nutrition or talking about
housing and all those things what
they're really saying is black lives
matter too but the data doesn't reflect
that whether we're talking about the
deaths of black people whether talk
about the health of black people at
every turn when you look at the data the
education of black tea when you
the data and a resources available to
black people and in the thriving of the
black community it's clear that black
lives don't matter as much as white
lives and here's the best way I can put
it obviously I'm a black male and I've
had my challenges from being a kid all
the way up to now being stopped
interactions with the police and so on
but I can't even relate to many of my
black brothers and sisters in these
impoverished communities so I even owe
it to them to listen to understand more
of the situation in the conditions
because I come from a different economic
level so if I being a black male have to
stop and listen and truly listen to
folks from black lives matter who are
feeling I mean why can't everyone else